The Joe Rogan experience.
This is our 50th year, Alex and I that's crazy.
Why is it crazy? But it's just amazing, you know,
crazy in a wild and awesome way. You know,
the fact that you guys have been doing music for that long. I mean,
that's pretty incredible.
We came out of this music three weeks outta high school,
school graduation. Whew. Okay. Our parents were very insistent. I.
Feel like I'm watching a movie. I've seen it all play.
Out right now. Yeah. Is, uh, the van healings,
their father and their mom said you're moving out. Okay.
They had jobs set up for them at the airport? No, she had his baggage handlers.
Okay. Um, I had been tossed outta house by mom,
mostly halfway through high school. Okay. So halfway through.
High school, she out.
Yeah. Yeah. What did you do? Um, well, I made my way,
ultimately I moved in with dad, but I finished high school. No, but I mean,
what'd you do.
That makes, made her kick you outta the house.
I was troublesome kid. Okay.
I was in and out the busing program.
It was a wild and colorful time. All right. This is the sixties you follow.
And there was constant conflict
in terms of where the van Hains went to school. For example,
as Pasadena high school, it was 90% Caucasian. We'll call it.
And other, I went to the schools that were all black and Spanish speaking.
So when I say <inaudible>, I mean it,
see you roll you tongue <laugh> that Al van,
he owns a 1956 Bellaire coupe. Mm. Okay. With the slicks on the back. Oh,
now you're talking, etc. Okay. That's pasts high school. Ah,
I own a lowered six Volkswagen with a 3 83 Chevy engine in the front local
<laugh> <laugh>
it's like the balance that made our music colorful. The M moniker diamond.
Dave comes from when I would go over to the van healing side.
That's like Ridgemont high. I went to like Cooley high. All right.
And their music was all led Zeppelin, uh, stones, the who?
Sabbath like this and starting at the seventh grade, um,
uh, youth club dance for me, that was all Motown, which, you know,
later my record collection was everything from Rick Chan and
you know, the I took Eddie V inhalant to his first black concert at the forum.
I think it was the only one that he ever went to was, uh, earth, wind and fire.
Whoa.
You saw earth, wind and fire live.
1976. Oh. When all the hits lifted up every famous earth,
wind and fire like this because I was gang signing whole alphabet from seventh
grade on, come on.
We knew where to go get Clipon ties and see through socks at meals when Alex van
Haen and I made our first lawsuit for 150 bucks on somebody who Welsh on a
check,
we went to a meals and we got clip on ties and we got proper socks
and we went out and sued them. You.
Follow, you sued someone.
For somebody. Uh, it was the, uh, and I say with respect,
the Mayfield school, the holy child of Jesus incorporated, Joe. And uh,
they said this was 1973. I said,
according to the contract that we had been smoking marijuana. No,
I know I came to the right place. Save yours.
<laugh> as a fact, we did not.
That was not possible because we didn't have enough money for it.
We would've full disclosure, full disclosure. Yep.
It's for 150 bucks. So Al and I,
and I know Al is listening right now. We laugh, like pirates on the phone. Okay.
And, uh, he, uh, uh, he and I went to, um,
uh, we got clip on ties. Okay.
And we went and we filed in the small claims division.
All right. Um, we stood in there and the, uh, uh,
the school showed up. There were two nuns and a family, a father, a mother,
and two young daughters. It was quintessential. This is 1973 in these days.
Like for example, here in Texas with long hair. Woo.
You better watch out over your shoulders of very, very different background.
Okay. This is now any kind of haircut goes these days,
but remember long hair in 1973 in a court of law.
Wow.
You were already on your back foot and we stood up thought we were fooling the
magistrate you followed with our long pony tails.
Remember what I used to look like, Joe, he's gonna look like Tarzan,
who read a few paperbacks. Come on. <laugh> <laugh> I was you Joe.
<laugh>.
Look at you. <laugh> look at you in nice. Exactly.
And you know, cheek bones for days, man,
you can sharpen a hunting knife on those cheeks, home.
Those chick. That's right. My beautiful man. You were, there we go.
I was gorgeous. Beautiful, man, man, I launched a thousand hips. <laugh> yeah.
<laugh>.
When.
You look back on that. No, I'm not. No, no. I'm not a sex symbol. You dig.
I'm not a sex object. It's I symbolize it. When you guys feel sexy,
I'm the MC I make other people feel sexy.
You come and you listen to van Hain music. You gimme three songs.
You're gonna feel young and skinny. You joke will feel invincible.
And your old lady will feel eminently desirable.
How much is that worth? Inestimable?
<Laugh> you got some good marijuana tell you that. When I walked in here,
like when, when I got to the studio, I was like,
the fog was thick in the building. As I passed. I'm like, Dave must be here.
Yeah. Well, I think there's definitely a benefit in kids learning, martial arts,
for sure. And learning martial arts in the same uniform.
There's a real benefit in that too,
because you realize it's not about the uniform.
It's not about what you look like. It's about getting things done.
Then as you learn and grow and, and become more accomplished,
then you re receive these belts.
And so then you have goal attainment and goal attainment is
an amazing thing for kids. An amazing thing for adults,
there's a real benefit in knowing that you put in the hard work and now there's
something that signifies it. Oh my God, I have a blue belt.
And they tie that blue belt around your waist.
And you're not a white belt anymore. And you feel proud.
You put that thing on and you feel like I have done work. And that it,
it elevates your perspective in terms of the way you look at yourself,
you look at your abilities, it gives you more confidence.
And it also gives you this goal. One day,
I wanna be a black belt and you just think about it like one day,
I'm gonna attain a rank of proficiency where I'm gonna be someone who's actually
to whatever level mastered a very specific style of martial art.
That's incredibly difficult to learn to. That's.
Good for everybody. You will fly that now to the arts that we do for a living
McCartney,
can't get through an interview without telling you about his six years in the
red light district in Germany.
He wears it like a General's badge. Can you dig it?
Mm-hmm <affirmative>, he's proud of it. Alex van. And he, and I,
same thing we put in five years compared to year three,
the average is two and a half. Maybe.
Following just constantly jamming, doing multiple shows constantly. Isn't that?
That's there's, it's detailed in the book, the outliers, right?
Is it the outliers? I think it is. Is, uh, there's a book outliers. Yeah.
They talk about how, when the beat emerged,
people don't realize they had so many hours of playing and it's one of the
reasons why they're so good is they were, they were playing so often,
constantly it.
Is really hardcore training.
And that's when you build who you are,
that's where you develop your ingredients. Yeah. When I was coming up in music,
that was the regular, because there were bands at every club.
Every bar had to have a live band to afford the speakers and the
turntable and the music.
You had to have a live band and you would tear off the left hand side of the
billboard chart and learn it. Alex.
And I went through a list just recently that we found of
120 songs that we could play at the drop of a hat
by everybody.
You could imagine from smoke on the water to get down tonight.
It's where we learned to sing. Get down tonight, get down tonight.
We didn't have keyboard. So you better sing.
You better sing a cover off that ball.
That's why Mike Anthony was so unique. His bass playing.
Now we could find bass players, but nobody sounds like that. That's Garfunkle,
Simon's good.
But Simon and Garfunkle where do you think you built that?
Thousands and thousands of vocal training hours so that when Mike and I
sing, you recognize it like Hendrix's guitar.
You may never have heard this song before and you go that's Hendricks,
signature, Sam, like rod Stewart's voice.
You may never have heard the song before you go that's rod. Yeah, it is.
And in our backgrounds like Motown,
that only comes from thousands of hours.
Where do you learn to have the 10 a tree to stick with that?
I learned it at the dojo. I learned it in my first singing lessons.
You dig it my first singing coach Jesus.
That was also my first real experience with tattoos.
We started off talking about tattoos. My first singing coach had two tattoos.
He had a number here and he had another number right there.
And he would say at least once a year,
this is my camp number.
And this is the number why I was still alive.
He played piano and he sang at Auschwitz Jesus. He's there for three years,
Kirk Blumenthal. Okay. And he used to tell me,
Mr. Roth sing as if your life depended on it.
Could you imagine a gig, one bad review literally puts you up the chimneys.
And that was another expression he would use.
It's in the music. It's in my voice.
It's in every van Haen song. You hear
Mr. Van Haen taught it to his sons, Jan van Haen.
And I were very good for friends.
And he would tell his sons about when the bombing would start
and they would all move into the subway tunnels and he would play saxophone for
everybody hiding during world II.
Every time I sing, I sing as if my life depended on it.
Catch new episodes. The Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog Jr E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on, on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.